so we continued to see absolute
bottom-feeding garbage coming out of fox
news about the virus and one primary
source of that trash really that pond
scum is the show Fox and Friends Fox &
Friends is hosted by Steve Doocy Ainsley
Earhardt and Brian Kilmeade here's a
clip in which Ainsley Earhardt talks
about how it's just so frustrating she's
staying outside the city new york city
she has an apartment in the city how
privileged bills are piling up she can't
get her nails done
she can't return the clothes she bought
that have a 30-day return policy can't
we do something about all this what's
interesting too you know we're talking
about this and everyday we're talking
about different topics because we're
moving in
hopefully the direction of getting to
where China is now or South Korea's now
and just getting some improvement let me
just stop there for one second even the
language of hopefully we're now going in
the direction of China and South Korea
is so bogus China shut everything down
for weeks and weeks
South Korea tested extensively did
contact tracing coordinated isolation
and Quarantine for weeks before they
turned the numbers around half of our
states haven't done a thing yet half of
our states haven't started fighting
coronavirus and it's part of the
propaganda that Donald Trump started
with on Sunday remember Sunday night
trump started with we don't want the
cure to be worse than the disease Monday
Trump started with people want to get
back to work Tuesday Trump said I'd love
people back to work by Easter Tuesday
night or maybe it was Wednesday Trump
said I want the churches packed on
Easter they're pretending like they're
winning this and they're not and Ainsley
Earhardt is doing it but the numbers
aren't improving it's just it's simply a
fantasy world it took two days to go
from 400,000 to 500,000 cases globally
in the US cases are increasing more
rapidly than in any other country and
Ainsley Earhardt is participating in
this propaganda of you know now that it
looks like things are sort of hopefully
starting to improve they're not we
haven't it's dangerous but let's
continue with the clip but I was
thinking you know we all I live in the
city you can't go back to the same you
can but I don't want to because I don't
want to
be around the area that's infected the
most but I'm thinking like all the bills
that are stacking up at my apartment you
know we've got to think about that kind
of thing if you bought clothing before
all this happen if you want to return it
or stores gonna gonna you know waive
that 30-day period where you can get
your money back if you need to return
something these are all the things
people are staying home women I mean you
don't think about this guy's butt and
you know this is not a priority but
women have to get their hair done your I
saw someone tweet out you're gonna see
what color are real hair is because our
roots are gonna grow in women all my
friends are saying you know this is not
a priority people are dying and I
realize that but they can't get their
nails done you know businesses are
closed everywhere it's just we're in
priority mode right now it's pharmacies
and it is grocery stores that those are
really the only places people are going
now Steve she has stuff she wants to
return to stores guys she can't get her
dye job done she can't get her nails
done how is this news what is this she
has to keep inserting the disclaimer
you'll notice people are dying I get it
people are dying but we can't get our
nails done I can't return my blouse to
H&M or wherever she shops it's a
microcosm of trumpism people are dying
and that's bad but I can't get my nails
done or return my clothes to the store
by the way I don't know much about this
can't you file and polish your own nails
like isn't that still something that we
women are able to do or whoever is uh
wants to file and paint their nails like
is that is that that much of a thing
people can't paint their own nails now
or am i stupid for thinking that imagine
when we get past this whenever it is
imagine our grandchildren saying grandma
is it true that you had to go months
without a professional manicure and you
weren't able to exchange some pants
because of the pandemic did that was did
that really happen grandma now it is
true that whoever does those blonde dye
jobs at FoxNews they may actually be
suffering hugely I was checking out a
picture of all the people at FoxNews
past and present who are relying on
those blonde dye jobs to avoid showing
the dark roots that Ainsley refers to it
they're certainly a lot that's going to
impact some businesses and of course
that's not good but this is just
continued gaslighting and propaganda
from fox news day after day after day we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today in which I am not at all involved
Fridays are producer Pat bonus shows
producer Pat is now quarantined sort of
just self isolated I call it quarantine
but it's not really that at his home
studio he's filming out of his gym where
you will see if you haven't watched any
of his bonus show appearances he has a
punching bag multiple mirrors various
tapestries and musical instruments a
ping-pong table that's where Pat has set
up his home studio and where he's doing
the editing so Pat's got the bonus show
today I will be back on Monday
hopefully assuming nobody catches the
virus or something else something worse
better who knows I look forward to
seeing you on Monday grab a membership
watch the bonus show join pakman.com or
patreon.com slash david pakman show